we got new merch three new shirts you
can check them out uh they're beautiful
they're nice if you're getting somebody
a Christmas gift this could be one get
on it early Rat King America gang gang
palm and the hitter 500 racing get all
that in more at theovon store.com thank
you so much for the support tour dates
we've added a third show in Atlanta
Georgia on December 1st at the Fox
Theater that's Friday so if you are a uh
that'll be the day before the uh SEC
National
Championship so so if you think your
team is going to be in it be a great
show to get a ticket to we also have
limited tickets left for evansv Val
Indiana on November 15th at the Ford
Center get all your tickets at theo.
comom and some sometimes I'll go uh I'll
go a month without thinking I breathe
you ever do
that you're like damn oh that's what I'm
supposed to be
doing I'm
just I need air to keep
going I'm like a kite you know I'm like
a
kite you know I'm like one of God's
kites we all
are you know it's like we need air to
keep
going
but I forget about that boy I I just
forget I just won't even take any I
won't even I guess I'm breathing but I
just don't even just I'm doing like a
little like
just just breathing but not you know not
like not
[Applause]
really you know I'm not doing the big
you know them Party Boys you know I'm
not taking them
big them big hits off the universe
like like I should be cuz that's good
for me big breathing they call it I
think when you're doing big breathing
boy but yeah I'm like that I'm like a
kite I think I forget that I forget to
fill myself with air what if you saw a
kite just just bouncing along the
sidewalk just rattling along you be like
damn that's a
that's the dumbest kite I ever
seen boy you be like kite
get some in air homie he's just
like I don't know can I have a cigarette
you know he's just like God that kite is
a that's why you
gotta you got to get that launch in you
[Applause]
baby but yeah anyway
breathing and this is kind of the time
of year I feel like I can finally
sometime take a
breath you know you can feel the
holidays right up there they're
coming you can hear the turkeys getting
scared as hell bro I saw a turkey the
other day on Etsy buying a shank
like damn the birds these birds know
what's up even a fat Sparrow you see him
getting a little uh some Talon
Chucks you know some uh some brass
ncks or some Talon you know some Talon
Chucks he just you know any fat Bird
right now getting ready to defend
itself cuz this that time what in the
hell is
that somebody's
gambling anyway um what are we talking
about sometimes I sometimes I forget to
breathe that crazy I do it but it's like
this little back it's like just this
like it's like this background breathing
that's just going along I'm not really
you
know saying all right breathing you want
to do some breathing I got you
homie me I'm not taking my lungs for a
walk you know I'm just putting down a
pee pad and just letting them pee there
you know that's what I'm doing when I'm
just kind of like just not F but
sometimes when I
go that's when I'm really taking my
lungs for a walk saying all right I'm G
take y'all to the lung Park you know
I'mma take I'mma throw the ball and
watch you go get it you know so that's I
think there's something about that
spending time with your lungs
instead of I take my lungs for granted
bro real talk I'll be honest man I take
my lungs for
granted I'll take I take my lungs for
granted my friend got bit by a shark
once and his lung got
um he got some of his lung got missing
or whatever it's called and then he di
he ended up dying actually a few years
later from um
um I don't even know what he died from
God people will die from anything they
don't even you know it's
like you're like damn that's how Sherman
died he feel like yeah that's how he you
know Sherman he didn't like to do you
know he was kind of like to just do his
own thing I guess but
um but yeah it's that time of year I
think
to
breathe
because it's when the wind picks up you
hear nature breathing like a you
know you see a kite you
know a kite is just out there just
trying to decode the wind baby a kite is
just a some is just some arts and craft
trying to the wind
bro that's all it is
man a kite is just some paper machete
that's trying to the wind
homie and that's on God baby you know
it yes Native American uh Heritage
cultural
month and um and yeah so I rolled up on
my boy my boy dreamer uh he does hair he
does hair over in uh in Los Angeles he
does it over off of uh off Ohio Street
in seula and he give Great Cuts man and
and I I rolled up on him once before
four and
uh and and I love him man he's really
good he's a really compassionate guy and
he was open I mean he was open I I guess
you're always open if you don't have a
real story you just have you know you
just setting up in in a uh in a
kind of like in a halfway house parking
lot or whatever so yeah but he's yeah he
he he he's open and so I rolled up on
him and I was driving by so I stopped
right and I get in the chair I was you I
was first in line or
whatever
and and yeah now this time I was in a
hurry I was in a hurry dude and I hate
to be in a hurry when you're when you're
like it's like dude we already you know
I didn't do it but we did some bad
people did bad stuff to Native Americans
bro I'm GNA say it I'm gonna say that
and uh
and you don't want to it's hard to be
like look I got nine you know I sat down
I like dude I got I just I'm in a hurry
you know and he just he he he just he
just gets real native you know he get he
real drops into the culture sometimes
you know he's just like he's like I am
of the W andot and the
mommy I am of the yendote and the mommy
I'm like I respect that bro but I
gotta get these sideburns evened up
Daddy I got I gotta be up the 101 and
eight minutes homie you know uh he's
just you know he he'll just be like in
the season of The Quiet Moon I'm like
bro um yes I agree with you but I gotta
we gota I need these bangs just a half
inch off these and I'm out you
know he's like in the Valley of the two
rivers like what are you talking about
bro I got a cic or what I got you know I
I just I respect the topography you're
doing but I gotta go homie you know do
you take vinm Mo he's like yeah in the
eve of the setting Sky oh you with Sun
Trust whatever it is brother uh yeah I
just I hate I hated that I had H hurry
butt um but I respect him man you know I
respect Native Americans I respect
anybody that's doing what they can um
I'm sorry about everything that happened
to Native Americans man I really am that
breaks my heart you know
oh and here we are trying to learn ways
to live off the land again we've gone
full circle I think because we're
realizing some of the patterns of our
civilization doesn't work out some of
the patterns the mythological patterns
of uh of capitalism and of those sorts
of things don't always work out so we're
looking for Solutions now so yeah hug a
damn native brother this holiday season
hug a native baby buy him a
squash you know you you know buy them a
uh
Cornucopia you know buy them a um pork
chop you know get them a get them a
beautiful piece of meat shank you know
but treat treat your native friends well
cuz they are the leaders they are the
champions of time so I'm really grateful
to been there and to have this cut and
especially them you know back in
the day n they'll they scalp you so
right when I sat down well when I sat
down his had uh his ra his uh truck
battery had died so we had to use my uh
I got a Cherokee I got a Cherokee dude
so we Ed a Cherokee to um do to jump
start his Clippers so that was good but
it was a little risky too because you
don't I don't know how much you know if
you got 470 volts rolling through a
set of Clippers dog that dude
will you know he'll open up a damn your
occipital if you ain't careful in that
he will damn he'll line you bro
he'll line you up with the Lord baby if
you're not real careful you know so God
that was at a high octave you know
the second he put it on the dogs were
howling you know couple streets over and
and um but we got it done so thank
you dreamer baby thank you I'm grateful
and happy um Native Heritage American
month brother it's time we quit
P bullshitting and we let these
loose dog we need to break
into these casinos and let these
loose bro and put them
back on horses and let them take let
them take over this that we're
living in now Native American heritage
month is observed in
November um so that was beautiful what
else we're going to talk to Tammy today
Tammy Manning she set the record for the
world's longest mullet and we want to
learn a little bit about her um and see
what's going on with her what else
um when it head doesn't work like it
used to
before and I can't keep you out of my
mind baby
I
you Ed Sharon lyrics boy got to see Ed
Sharon's baby I got to the ca Edge
sharing here's what happened so I had
some shows in Las Vegas and thank you
for coming out somebody urinated on
someone at one of the shows they said it
was an accident it couldn't have been
but that's okay baby God does stuff like
that and we move forward um but it was
really really exciting been doing some
bigger shows just because even at this
rate I'm going to be on tour for the
next year so um I know there's some
places where tickets have sold out don't
go pay extra for fancy tickets we'll
come back and get you get it in a fair
rate so don't do don't do that don't
feel bad
um but yeah so anyway I got to go hang
out uh I got to go see the chain smoker
right I've uh seen them before in
passing but I've never gotten to go see
their um he their uh Bann so I go right
I'm having a nice time it's Halloween
night and I'm pretty pretty beat it's
been a long uh couple years or whatever
so um I'm just enjoying it it's a great
show and Ed shearan comes out and Ed
Sheeran's baby you know if you if you
never seen Ed Sheeran baby you know he's
just I mean he's
from he's from another
country and when he comes out man he
means
it he's almost like uh
it almost seems like he's like s like he
could be related to Santa because he
came on stage and it was a the vibe was
great right but he comes on and he was
having so much
fun um that it just changed the whole
energy it just like took the whole
energy of the place into like a new like
another level of
joy and it was just nice to see and that
things that he was he he it was
Halloween and he just he was dressed
like a part of like a muffler like a
catalytic converter something it was
like a helmet I don't remember what it
was crazy look like a car part or
something um like a like a hero at uh at
Auto Zone right um and he roll he comes
out on stage on in that right and just
you know half of a uh air filter cover
with eye holes and he's just having a
blast man he was having so much
fun and uh and it took it just made
everybody have such a good time and so
then like you would think oh if it's a a
DJ set because chain smokers are DJs
right they play DJ music so they played
like Ed Sheeran's like most upbeat song
I don't know I don't have it here in
front of me but and if you're on the
YouTube you can hear you can see I'm
putting video in here because that's
what I'm doing today with this and um
but then they as soon as the song would
end he thought he was just going to do
like one song with the chain smoker guys
then he they would start one of his next
songs all right
so so it kept getting like more ballady
you know cuz he sings like a lot of
ballads and just you know he's you know
he's got that emo Ed baby he's the you
know um he's that you know he's that emo
ganger baby that's who he is and um and
he's a masterful at it and and so it
kept getting more ballady and so at
first you were like no way everybody's
just going to go along with this because
it was kind of this up it was like this
you know it was more hype in there and
then everybody just goes more and more
ballades till it's like we're almost
just at a uh at a Ed shearan Show um and
I think by the end he's singing perfect
and everybody's like singing along
people are crying somebody's admitting
to somebody else that they're their real
parent or something right next to me I'm
like what what the homie get a Jin
and tonic and chill dude you about to
pay some back child support buddy that's
insane brother
um but it was just it was just intern to
see if if you somebody shows up with a
good
energy and or if somebody really shows
up and with a good energy that it can
change the vibe of a
space um so that was just a neat it was
just it was just a neat reminder to see
that live and in person so I want to let
you know also this holiday season we're
going to do something called relative
Rodeo where if you if you can get you
know here's how you do it what you want
to get is somebody hugging somebody in
the family they don't usually
hug so you know be like hey Jonathan go
hug
Vanessa and one of you just secretly
kind of films
it and it's relative Rodeo how long can
you hold you know now don't don't get
obs seen don't you know nobody needs to
ejack or nothing this is calm this calm
behavior these are good people but yeah
that's what it is we're just going to
see want to promote some love out there
cuz sometimes you know Uncle Henry's
over there and he don't like anybody
getting close to him or he will
chew his own shirt
off you know cuz he's got you know he's
got shingles in his
brain so
that's when you tell you know get a
family member say won't you go hug him
let's see how long you can stay on him
and just send me that those videos and
that's for during Thanksgiving time you
know no need to do it now but I'm just
letting you know and that'll be relative
rodeo and we'll make a a montage and put
it up there um I want to thank you guys
for checking out the Tucker Carlson
episode I thought it was
interesting you know it's just nice to
get to spend time with uh somebody and
chat with him
um yeah that's all yeah people ask do I
have a big plans a lot of times with
podcasts sometimes I have some things I
like I would like to talk about and
sometimes I get scared to talk about
them um I'm trying to be more Brave
sometimes I feel like I don't know
enough you know it's like damn I don't
know enough about this to really comment
on
it um and things like that
so but I was just grateful for his time
man I'm grateful for everybody's time I
can't believe that we get to sit and and
chat with some you know different types
of folks and you know the world really
is becoming uh a lot smaller in a lot of
ways so let me see what else I got
here baby
I
new I am of the W and do and the mommy
uh yeah can you I gotta shave my neck up
home we got a you know what I'm saying
all dreams spin out from the same web uh
yeah of course they do um do you
take
Paypal you know may the Stars carry your
sadness away yeah I love that I also
um yeah I need you to get a little bit
more right above my
ears
if the white man wants to live in peace
with the Indian he can live in peace
treat all men alike give them all same
law give them all an even chance to live
and grow all men were made by the same
great spirit Chief they all are brothers
the Earth is the mother of all people
and all people should have equal rights
upon it
wow that's really profound
man that's really profound
I just saw this on this on this
website um you I'm trying to think of
what's been going on with me man um off
of
masturbation so that has been nice uh I
did actually I did I I have done it I
have done
it
um but I'm not I'm off of
pornography I'm off of pornography I've
seen some light
pornography um or semi- accidental I
would say um in the past 50
days um two two
jpegs two jpegs in the last 50 days and
um I like that my brain is start my
imagination is starting to come back a
little in the middle of the day I'll
just imagine a damn ass cheek
bro I'll just imagine an ass cheek and I
don't find my myself thinking as much
perved out my brain isn't as perved
out it's
like it's
nice yeah my brain deserves
that you know I shouldn't be showing my
brain all that booty and all of that ass
and everything so so that feels pretty
good what else is going on the holidays
are coming up I am excited
uh oh I got to take my niece to her
first concert dude that was so
fun that was so fun man we went to see
Laney Wilson and
Hardy and uh she' been going through
some things and um she was my first
niece that ever existed you know and I
remember when she was born I was
just man she
really she really started to kind of
change our family some because it was
the first thing that we we all had that
we could all care about for our own
reasons you know
uh but that we all cared about it we all
cared about it and um our family needed
that we'd never had any we'd never had
anything like that really and uh so
she's always had a real special place in
my heart you know and and she's cool
she's she plays soccer and she's like
she's amazing right and so she's funny
she's creative she's got a huge she's
going she
has she adds she's chat you know she's
chatty she's always commun you know she
got something to say or Share She's
energetic um so yeah but it was cool man
we got to go see Laney who and then
Laney let her come back and meet her so
dude I was so I was it was just fun so
that was really exceptional and um and
we got to watch Hardy you know Hardy
who's been on the podcast too and it was
just it was uh you know cuz people will
always be like when's your first concert
and uh and she can say that and so that
was you know that was neat um if you're
looking for one of the best gifts ever
this holiday season I got to let you
know about something I got electric
ebikes will impress even the hardest
person to shop for on your list they're
just
interesting they're sleek and stylish
you feel like you're kind of in the past
past and in the future they have a
very
um
Speedy electricity is in it it's a bike
and has electricity in it andan it's
fascinating it's a perfect gift for the
Explorer the Eco Warrior and the parent
on your list or as a treat for yourself
and starting at just $799 these ebikes
are friendly on your wallet plus you can
get hundreds of dollars in free
accessories when you purchase this
holiday season at
electric l c t r i c e b i ke s.com
that's LCT
I bikes.com I've ridden this bike and I
love getting somewhere on it you get the
feeling I want to go you
go you're gone that's it electric has
ebikes for everyone in the family from
the passenger ready Expedition cargo
ebike to the ultral accessible XP trike
that's right get hundreds of dollars in
free accessories with any electric ebike
purchase this holiday including
America's bestselling ebike the XP 3.0
visit electric ebikes.ca
for you that's LCT r i c e b i ke
s.com look I realized just from
traveling from the constant um
thinking uh moving around the changing
of the weather
the dehydrating summer I've realized
more than ever how hydrated I need to
stay that's right thanks to liquid IV
that's easily possible you don't have to
be an athlete to need extra hydration
throughout your day Zoom meetings bird
watching tickling
somebody and even just that long
summer left us all a little bit
dehydrated liquid IV hydrates two times
faster than water alone and they do it
all in a single stick and now their
hydration multiplier comes in three
delicious sugarfree flavors white peach
green grape and lemon lime grab your
liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid.com and use code Theo at checkout
that's 20% off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today today
using promo code Theo at liquid
i.com this episode is sponsored by
bluechew yep do you want to bring the
heat in the bedroom you can blue Chu can
help you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
bluechew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra Calis and Levitra but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
blue Chu's tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and Shi direct to your door
in a discreet
package they always say first
impressions are important what about
Lasting
Impressions go to bluechew.com and use
code Theo to receive your first month
free just pay $5 blueo get that Wier
going blue blue they've got a special
deal for our listeners try blueo free
when you use our promo code Theo at
checkout just pay $5 shipping that's BL
blue.com promo code Theo to receive your
first month free visit blue.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank blue for sponsoring the
podcast put your head on my
[Music]
shoulder put your head on my
shoulder the old days man it must have
been romantic back then
huh romantic boy you see a girl
and her skirt moves a certain way and
you just you're M the inside of your
mouth just gets damp
oh you don't even need any gum back
then people was so horny
bro people was so
horny back then oh you'd see a girl put
a baret on across the classroom and when
it snapped
close God God your butt would get
[Music]
wet boy you bad boy your butt would get
wet I
bet cuz you was so horny back then
brother you was God you was so
horny I remember
oh I remember one girl one time she had
a necklace or something and it got
caught in a button on her shirt right
she had like a pretty long necklace like
I think it was a good necklace for our
area but it wasn't real nice you know
nobody knew that it wasn't nice though
because nobody had anything nice and it
got caught in this button and she UND
did this
button and at an
angle I seen a
like a brawl like a lace
brawl just a damn just just and it was
right on the edge of a oh of her breast
and it was just like a damn titty
doily it was just a damn titty doily
baby and God oh my God every pimple on
my face burst at the same
time it was like The Fountains at the
Bellagio it was
just it I mean it was oh my God I didn't
and the inside of my throat got all
wet I could not handle myself
well when I was a child you know at that
age boy you show up and you were just
oh you God I
remember you know I remember one time I
tie my shoe lace got caught on something
I fell on the ground and just came I
just your body you just like
oh somebody's like are you hurt dude I'm
like H yeah
I I am and it's great you know hurt keep
hurting
me you know it just was a different time
anyway
sorry you got to get it out of your
system brother you got to get it out of
your system baby
[Music]
I'm going to do that it's winter it's
nober you know that it's native let's
see look it up and see what it means
what does
nober
mean the 11th month of the
year
H what else we got to call that came in
right here let's hear
Ito it's pton from down in New Orleans
and I'm wondering what's up Payton right
there and uh thank you for calling
brother and tell Eli and Arch I said
what's up and
Cooper no but I hear he's nice guy
onward why don't we see more black
ghosts where are all the black
ghosts I feel like they're
underrepresented in the ghost Community
oh dang
bro where the black ghost at
man they might be running late bro they
could be
just you know I don't know if what that
you
know I don't
know what the afterlife is
like and maybe black people been through
a lot they might be like we ain't
we done you know we take you
know
we a we we we we done we you know we a't
do we
ain't showing up and you don't even get
paid ghost don't even get paid so that's
we ain't doing that I know that but
yeah they probably could just be running
late baby you know that come
on uh what else we got another call that
came in um and then I'll look at a
little bit of news
too
[Music]
uh Hey Theo it's uh it's Jake from
Indiana Jake what's up
brother um let's hear more uh I got I
got a issue that's been uh on me for a
while you know what I'm saying how do
you deal with being a sibling
of a younger sibling of someone who's
very
successful and you just don't feel like
you have the right tools to do what they
did and um being a young man in a
factory and that's all you got to your
name sometimes it feels like you're not
doing enough with yourself at least
that's where I'm at
anyway thanks for the call Brother
um yeah you know uh I felt this a lot
with my brother um you know I
felt there are times where I feel less
educated than him you know
um less capable
um you know um sorry I'm not trying to
make this about me but I'm just sharing
I can relate to a little bit of that but
I think that you have to look at your
family as a group in a way you have to
look at your blood
as the
uh that's the sort of the marker for you
you know you're all part you you know it
takes everybody to get somebody out of
the mud sometimes
it takes
everybody you know sometimes you might
have an older sibling that took a couple
L's so you didn't have to you know you
might have somebody that's dealt with
addiction or dealt with
um you know took like abuse from a
parent or something so then you the next
kid then you know it's like it's all
uh so one person's success is really
it's a familial it's a familial effort I
think um so I think if there's a way to
take pride in
it uh as a family like wow look what our
family has accomplished here you know we
have a family member that's a a great
singer or a family member that's a great
artist or a family member that is
um uh a teacher a doctor a nurse um that
started their own mechanic shop or um
that is uh a great father that's a Hu
that's another part we don't look at
sometimes about
success yeah if some if somebody says
Hey show me your success what would you
show them a picture of your family would
you show them a degree you've gotten
would you show them an award that you
won um would you play for them something
that you made or would you show them a
house that you had built or painted um I
think there's a lot of things like that
unfortunately I think we have a society
sometimes that doesn't measure a lot of
successes like that but that's just our
society's choice this time I don't think
that that's a
realistic uh I think that is a error in
know errorful way that we have gone off
on
um
but uh what else yeah man but yeah I
think in trying to
have trying to maybe some I fantasy like
I have a sister that's a nurse on I'll
put my like wonder what she's doing or
um think about if she's giving somebody
IV or she's sitting there joking
laughing with her co-workers or
something or you know and I'll almost
pretend like I'll pretend like I'm there
being her for a second or you know my
brother uh is a he's uh tree guy you
know he did trees for a long time and
and now he uh is doing some more
entrepreneurial like trying to learn
some arts and stuff like that and um
music theory and different things that
he really enjoys uh and now he's doing
different stuff and um but I was always
so envious that he had like a business
you know we had like a you know we had a
handful of employee but he you know and
he but he woke up and he had a business
and I always I don't know there would be
sometimes I would like just fantasize
that I was sitting in the work truck
with him or um I don't know but yeah
it's hard it's hard not to be envious um
and I think some of that can come at
times that's normal it's just like
recognizing it
and and also I think if it's a family
member that's had some success they'll
recognize the the parts that you've had
in the making of their success you know
yeah hang in there baby you got this man
what else do we got
um somebody right here praise God what's
up Theo my name is
Clay what's up Clay baby hell yeah boy
and Clay son that's a very native
American thing
clay you know you ever meet somebody
like named clay and then you just
try to shape them into something
different like hey I'm clay you're like
you're a bull
now uh let's hear more escaping right
now I'm achete in a tree and yesterday I
was going to the
gym and uh I got scammed these dudes
pulled up up on me trying to sell some
speakers mhm the old trick but uh yeah
they got me good got me for
$1,000 hard earned money right there but
uh love the podcast love the show keep
on
going Praise Baby I'm sorry that
happened to you thank you for getting it
out of your system here people get
scammed all the time 70 out of a 100
people have been
scammed finessed they call it people get
taken advantage
of but that's the bro you now
you gotta keep that machete on you
dog keep that machete on
you but yeah you you buy a couple
speakers next thing you know you open a
box and instead of some Rockford five
skates you just got a couple of just
rocks in there you got damn just two
you got two two 14 inch pieces
of shell in there you're like damn
brother so it's unfortunate man all
right we got involved in a damn pyramid
scheme we got
uh somebody was doing glitter mining by
us a man came through
and over by the damn Gibson's parking
lot and they got about 12 of
us and we lost all that man they
never paid up
and oh ended some marriages and
everything some of one of the marriages
was illegal anyway so they shouldn't
even have been honestly so that
was a blessing you never know where the
blessings are going to come in
baby oh
God what
else hey Theo this is Nick calling from
Brooksville Florida what's up big
Nick and Nick rhymes with um dick di k
dick they can say it let's hear more
Nick I was just wondering thought you
you thought I was gonna say dick didn't
you let's hear more buddy uh I wanted
some advice from you so I just graduated
high school I became a welder so now I'm
doing that amen baby way to get a trade
right out the gate get a
trade hell yeah dude but I'm working
night shift right now so I really don't
get to see a lot of friends family
anything like that so I was thinking
that maybe when I turn 19 I might join
the Law Enforcement Academy and try to
go down that route just wanted to see
what your opinions were on that and what
you think I should do yeah brother I
love it I think we need more good
officers out there and people you sound
like you can you know are able to
verbally communicate clearly and um yeah
in America that's enough to give you a
weapon and get you out there so I think
you should do it man man and you could
weld too brother that'd be sick just
weld a inmate to the back of a
car something weld that in if
somebody's real bad you just if
somebody's a killer a murderer you just
W just weld them just bead right
along that doorline and just weld them
in the back you know and then
put a couple damn bees in there couple
of God's air ninjas in that
and let them
loose God I want you to be a cop so yeah
I'm all for it brother I like your
attitude you're creating possibilities
for yourself you're creating
experiences it's so crazy how the second
you decide to do something and you go
take the first step the other steps are
a billion times
easier it's
unbelievable um I'm proud of you man
nothing changes if nothing changes baby
you want to do something different you
got to do something different
praise God daddyy thank you man for
calling it made me feel excited for some
reason I think sometimes I live
vicariously through other people's jobs
you know kind of like I was saying about
my family or uh people that are you know
somebody calls in and or a bus driver a
farmer doing deliveries you know there's
things I used to love like I used to
love to get to paint uh I worked on my
buddy's farm and I would do painting
over there and I would get stung by bees
and bitten by animals and I loved it out
there and they gave me a gun too and I
shot
uh I shot a hole in this in a water
reservoir and
um and I lost my
job but uh anyway sorry what was I
talking about um but yeah some of them I
like to
fantasize when else we got going what's
going on in the news right here the
Native American it's Native American
heritage month I want to say thank you
man I want to say thank you
um you know I'm qu I think I'm eighth
something eighth Pontiac or something
yeah my father had some type of um
Indian in him and it was some South
American Indian
um but some of that blood flow through
him you know
and oh I think we've taken such a detour
from being so disconnected from our
Earth and planet and I think it's one of
the reasons why we have so much sickness
in the world today and mental emotional
sickness because we're just supposed
to be part
of
Nature and we are on some other
we're on some other I want to
ask you something is porn causing a
problem in your
life it's a good question do you find
yourself watching porn too much is it
affecting your relationship is it
affecting your dating life well you're
certainly not alone if that's happening
for you you know porn or porno as some
people have called it is so commonplace
today and people use it and men use it
to numb the pain of loneliness boredom
anxiety
depression shame and stigma prevent men
from talking about these issues and
getting help for them but I want to
introduce you to my friend Steve Walt
who is the founder of Valor recovery a
program to help men overcome porn abuse
and sexual
compulsivity Valor recovery helps men to
develop the tools necessary to have a
healthier sex life their coaches are in
long-term recovery and will be your
partner mentor and spiritual guide to
transcend these problematic behaviors to
learn more about Valor recovery please
visit them at
www. Valor recovery
coaching.com or email them at admin
Valor recovery
coaching.com we will put all that
information in the uh description below
I couldn't recommend reaching out to
them more if uh if this is something
that you have struggled with I want to
let you know about keeps that's right
keeps is an online subscription service
that makes it easy and more affordable
for men to treat their male pattern
baldness from the comfort of their own
home why have to go out and about to
debal yourself and and get unbaled
keeps they have clinically proven
treatments to address hair loss and
boost hair regrowth delivered right to
your door in discreet packaging the
neighbors won't be saying hey there look
at Lonnie's getting hair delivered
Lonnie oh Lonnie we know whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
growth or just take better care of the
hair you have keeps has you covered
that's right to date keeps has helped
nearly 1 million
men hair loss stops with keeps for a
special offer to get started go to
keeps.com Theo or click the link in the
description that's ke ps.com
tho that's right thanks to keeps for
sponsoring this video head to
keeps.com Theo to get a special offer
today's episode is brought to you by
better help if you need help if you if
you aren't lined up if you aren't
connecting with yourself if things have
gotten astray you're not the only one I
take anti-depressants right now I'm I
was in therapy yesterday you know when
you need it you need it and if it's at
time for you that's okay give it a shot
better help that's right they can match
you with a licensed therapist just fill
out a brief questionnaire and you can
switch therapist at any time for no
additional charge if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online it's convenient
flexible and can suit to your schedule
you can connect with your therapist over
phone um FaceTime or or uh or even just
text whatever you
need
therapy it's okay that's what I'm
telling you make your brain your friend
with better help visit betterhelp.com
Theo today to get 10% off your first
month that's better
hp.com
EO this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp she's from Knoxville
Tennessee and she's the grower of the
world's longest mullet she's verified
and yeah damn baby she could grow grapes
on that thing my God Tammy Manis Tammy
manace nice to see you today
thank you so much for having me yeah
congratulations on you got that scalp
lava baby you got all of it I've got it
all fluffy today God and what you taking
it for a walk is that a kind of a sun
the way you set it up for a Sunday or is
there How does it go throughout the week
the the the hair care how is it it it it
does not frol it freely during the week
but uh I have my friend with me this
weekend I have a family get together and
so we can coordinate with doing this and
the getting it braided I have to keep it
braided because otherwise uh by the end
of the day my tail is dragging all of my
tails are dragging because it's actually
longer than I am oh wow so you've really
outdone yourself literally it's one of
those things it's like really you tried
to do that no just life happened I
haven't have it yeah did you get
forgetful were you in a coma or
something how'd you get it that long how
long is
it it is 68 inches long when it's fully
stretched out I'm only 64 inches tall
all okay so there you go you Val yeah
wow that's so long and do you get scared
like you cuz you it must be a little
risk in there huh like if you you know a
mistake and you're a box fan or
something like that and you you're your
afternoon could change are you being a
neck brace I I I know where my tail is
I'm pretty tail aware now okay so and
like I said it stays in a braid so and
where I work I usually wear a back brace
because I'm old and it tames the tail
okay I see and when I sit down it's
funny my nurse manager she actually says
I laugh every time you sit down to draw
blood because I automatically just throw
it over my left leg oh yeah it's like I
know where it is that's beautiful yeah
there's something lovely about that you
know does it almost does it almost feel
like a pet does it almost feel like a
friend or something oh no not a
bit it's just it's something I've had
for 33 and a half years now so yes it is
a part of me yeah oh yeah I can imagine
well you know I have a just a starter
kit going on the on the back of my head
but I um hey dude you got a mullet
you're good well we'll see you know I it
feels like me once my hair got longer it
just felt like me it was like oh this is
where I'm always supposed to be this is
the way I've my head is supposed to have
been do you feel most comfortable with
your hair like that like would you feel
very out of sort you think if you had to
take it off
off I I saw something once and somebody
had just come up and cut somebody's hair
and it made me
nauseous wow I actually had a tail prior
to this one uh back in
80 889 and I cut it and it was only you
know probably about five or six inches
which I still have oh yeah and I
immediately felt this angst I was like
okay that ain't gonna happen so February
9th 1990 I started growing this one so
yes it has a birthday yeah
so how old is it it is 33 and a half
it'll be 34 years February the 9th
praise God baby and if we plucked a
strand of it or a cord of it and we
tested it it would it what would it test
positive for because you got a long well
I always told I told everybody I
couldn't do drugs in my life because you
can literally do a drug test on hair and
I would have been in so much trouble but
I've been a good girl I don't do that
stuff oh yeah yeah yeah damn boy because
yeah I think yeah there's just so much
of it you'd really be able to just kind
of
you could probably find the exact Friday
night that you smoked a joint if
somebody wanted to get real particular
on there how what do your mother think
of it what does she think of your long
hair and your world record now because
you you're in the record books aren't
you yes I I I actually have my beautiful
tenness world record book here yeah
that's so cool and I yeah I said I've
I've U show me your page let me see what
page you're
on Wow
shorty that's
awesome but back to my mom I said
somebody made a negative comment once
and they said oh they must be so proud
and I said well actually my mom's
probably up in heaven looking down
laughing her butt off now yeah my mom
passed away a few years ago but yeah I
think she would think it was hilarious
oh that's cool yeah she's probably
getting a good laugh out of it oh oh
yeah she' probably be like well it's
just your hair I'm like yes Mother no
people what are what are some of the
nicknames you got like maybe I was
trying to think of something maybe Billy
Ray puns maybe or I'm trying to think of
I like that one really very funz though
I think I probably started mine before
he had his no it's just it's just it's
just the tail everybody knows me for my
hair I mean people can't remember my
name but they go I want the one the long
hair yeah and it was it was so funny
because when I was on um deployment with
the state guard during coid I was in
uniform all the time so after I got off
Co and I got hired at the health
department I didn't have to have my hair
tucked anymore because I did in uniform
the people were just
like you've always had that I said yeah
I just knew how to hide it wow
so yeah you never know what people are
hiding these days boy somebody you never
know oh yeah somebody I work in public
health tell me about it God damn yeah
dude you never know somebody will show
you a mold that they can piss out of you
know you just know it's just a weird
world out there I tell people I could
strangle you and they'd be looking for a
rope okay yeah now we're talking huh you
ever done any light crime with it Tammy
oh no I mean it's like you know with all
the people out in the world you know the
hair and everything n and I don't need
that career
yeah um what about any long-term plans
with it if you considered maybe doing uh
Locks for Love or or locks for lust even
hell I'd buy a damn half a foot and make
a damn orgy towel out of it or something
I mean I bet you got to realize you got
the threat that's what I was saying
somebody said you know about only fans
you know hair I said no no no I I have a
i' like to keep a decent image um no
I've had people say so are you going to
cut it now and I told the uh news person
I said let me think about that no yeah
I'm very blessed because not everybody's
hair will grow long that's that's a
great Point set that's a great point so
you're almost doing it for the people
that can't do it even there's a little
bit of that in there sure sure we'll go
with that and now when you say if you go
to heaven one day right and you uh what
what where you does the hair go with you
does
it um I hope somebody's up there that
can braid it for me oh yeah because I
can't do it by myself I have to have
somebody do it for me now that's kind of
interesting you have to have a partner
really to get to keep that hair well yep
and she's been in some of the videos
that Guinness put out because they they
did a whole photo shoot which was really
cool yeah and they've done different
videos and I found a lot of them online
I mean because this story got out which
was amazing MH and I mean some of the
people's got the video of uh my brother
who is more technological than I am he
actually filmed a whole thing where she
took it down and he did it in fast
motion and then we did a whole time of
raing it because it takes her about an
hour and 15 minutes to braid it by the
time she yeah by the time she braids it
and rewraps it because I put a little
crochet floss at the top keep from
getting so fuzzy put little beads on the
end oh damn I think you getting it ready
for church huh and what kind of Sav you
put in it you put any Sav or something
minute what do you guys do over there
well you know I joked with somebody
because they asked uh are you get any
hair care product promos I said no but
I'm already made commercial for Main and
tail hair and conditioner come on oh
yeah yeah oh I bet half the Preakness
gets pissed if you walk by they
get re Them Ponies will show out I'm
sure yeah it's actually a pretty good
product but I've used several things
through the years but I like stuff with
our gun I have shampoo condition and
then um leave in conditioner right
before she braids it oh that's beautiful
God that's beautiful and it gets it gets
Reb braided about once a week M my it
sounds it sounds damn Majestic really it
sounds Royal it really does I don't know
if if you see it it comes all the way up
oh yeah God oh yeah like if I if I can
get you it's kind of hard to show the
whole thing just I get it baby of its
length oh my God yeah it kind of fluffy
you tell the Irish in me there with the
reddish oh yeah oh sure yeah um I say
that's impressive I'm like okay thank
you now you ever caught a lover on it
you ever put a little chicken liver on
the end of it or a butterscotch or
something and just kind of you you got a
little toe line for you there I know no
but I I'm always careful if I'm around
cats because they think it's a building
cat toy right there oh they do don't
they they don't have a heart do
they it's something I've dealt with so I
know how to deal with it but it's um
it's a it's a conversation piece yeah
well it sure is well it brought us here
to talk to you today Tammy and I just
want to say thanks yeah a for just doing
something unique you know it's fun to do
something unique in your life and and
people don't realize there's all types
of ways to find some way to be creative
or to be expressive and uh I think
that's just such a nice reminder um and
hey I'm just who I am that's what I tell
everybody I said I just try to be nice
do my job well and and one I had did one
negative comment well one I had several
when all this came out and people were
making some negative comments and I'm
like they were talking about the state
of the world I said yes I'm in
healthcare I understand how the world is
if this gives somebody something to
smile at laugh about make fun of
something different oh yeah if it takes
your mind off of stuff going bad that's
fine with me I'm good with it oh you
could stand by any River in Louisiana
and you could charge a nickel every time
somebody want a rope swing off into that
thing honey I'll say that oh wish I can
make a nickel off every time somebody
made a comment about it really now
that's fair that's fair look that hair
tariff baby that's it look that that
counts um is there a Meetup is there a
Meetup for the Guinness world record
holders you guys do an event do you get
to meet the guy with the longest uh
tooth or the sharpest elbow or the you
know the guy who's been underwater for a
month or whatever like is there a um you
know is there any that I know of I know
there's mullet meat UPS people have
different I am that's for drugs so let's
just call that is I might have to turn
that job down as a judge next year I was
asked about well look the I just saying
the ones at the rest area are I'll tell
you that that's for sure yeah God bless
those people yeah we just wanted to say
hey Tammy you know we know there's been
a lot of hype and hoopla and um and I've
gotten I've gotten tagged in so many
pictures wanting us to say hey to you
and and get to spend a little bit of
time so just want to say congrat yeah
congratulations and thank you so much
for uh for chatting with us today we
appreciate
you I know my brother's thrilled because
when I first got the invitation we
couldn't hook up and I my brother was
checking on my social media I actually
gave him the passwords and he goes oh my
God I missed the invitation from Theon
I'm like I don't have time to check all
this stuff so I was looking you up and
I'm like oh crap all those people I'm
going to be the most boring interview
he's ever done and he wants to talk to
me okay
n you're great you're you're doing
something unique you know I could I you
know I don't have anything you know I'm
not going to say I never been the owner
of anything long but you know I never
really you know I got God G God gave me
what he gave me you know and that's fine
with us so somebody said you know other
people have long hair I said I know
people who can sing but they're not on
the voice yeah it's just how lucky you
get with what you got y I'm thankful and
I'm happy amen I like your attitude
happy holidays to you Tammy and thank
you for your time tonight you as well
keep your mullet going keep it Trimm
you're good yeah I'll see you maybe I
might see you in the mullet streets next
year all right hey take care thank you
so much you too darling bye bye bye
thank you Tammy not often you get to
talk to this a real Vine of society
right there just want
of God just want a mother nature's damn
just just a firm of
beauty oh that's beautiful that tail boy
you hang that thing out of window at
night boy seven
raccoons hump it baby God praise God
thank you
Tammy all right this is a call that came
in thank you for hitting the hline it's
as always the hotline is 98566
49503 let's hear this hey Theo my name
is Alex I'm from Denmark and Denmark
baby Denmark did it it yeah Ricky done
it then Mark did
it onward brother I want to start off by
saying thank you for uh being you I um
I've been through a year of depression
and um watching your videos and your
insights everything from your humor to
how you tackle the deeper questions in
life it's truly inspirational and it's
been a big light in in my existence at
least and I am sure from any others well
thanks man that's a nice thing for you
to say man um yeah I'm just trying to
just trying to do my best man just
trying to stay alive baby and uh but
yeah uh that's very that's a nice thing
for you to say onward brother uh during
this
time um I have two questions for you
number one I have Asbergers so I'm all
autism M baby as you would say damn baby
you got the Euro ISM baby
gang bro W woo
we never had that on it bro
we never had the exchange rate on that
freaking tism bro that tiim or whatever
they call it over there you
know we never had that exchange rate on
that t we never had that baby we
never had it so God good to see you baby
deuts Mark baby with that
TM yeah dude dude I knew that
would make it overseas baby you're all
going to get it praise God boy
we're all going to be playing
Zelda Somewhere In Hell Baby Let's Hear
It onward sorry man
sorry onward this mou baby as you would
say which I love by the way um how would
you go about a first date like how would
you ensure that date doesn't tism out
fully my second question to you is well
first of all this how you do a first
date man you don't you don't do no you
don't try to do no sex you don't try to
do no titty you don't try to do no booty
hole or nothing you do regular you do
communication you do uh constant
um uh positive energy you know you do
learning get some coffee and uh maybe
have a
uh oh it's up already
snack have a snack you got to do
something easy drop somebody off get
them an Uber don't try to make all the
magic
happen don't tell because there's no
magic left in the sack
homie there's no magic left in the sack
baby you got to leave some magic in the
sack so that's what I would do and if
you have autism or whatever you got baby
Asbergers
bers whatever you got dog
one of the wall Burgers one of
them's got the Ronnie or whatever
uh tell them straight up hey baby you
know I'm that
I'm that Spectrum donkey
homie tell her straight up tell her show
her where you at on that Spectrum bring
her
ruler you know so that'll help baby
you're gonna be fine baby I'll tell a
lot of chicks will they'll love a dude
who got a problem as long as
it's an energetic one as long as if you
do yard work and you get out
there and you build a
[Music]
uh a travoli fountain or whatever out of
the leaves or some kind of she's
going to love you dude if you build a uh
arch of
trium out of the damn um you know out of
some you're supposed to pull out of
the garage she going to love you brother
and that's God working with you
onward um I've noticed in your latest
few videos you're wearing these really
cool black Aviator style sunglasses I
was curious could you you share the
brand and M of those because I would
love to get them for myself carry a bit
of Theo swag on my day hell yeah baby
and these are these autism
blinders
baby these are the autism blinders dog
they see me T in they
ha
bro knock knock who's there
autism where the hoes at
not
here um I don't know what these are man
I don't know even where I got them I've
been trying to find a sunglass company
that will partner or something with us
and help us get some um awareness out
there or get some Sunglass out there
maybe we would do a good tism shade
maybe that wouldn't be nice because
really autism is just a SE it's just
kind of like a God puts a filter on your
shade in a way and it's like a unique
shade that we don't know that much about
and so I think that would be pretty cool
so one of our goals next year is to get
into uh doing some supportive stuff so
it's just been hard you know I got to
get some more help and
um you know this year we've really spent
a lot of our spare time just uh trying
to build the podcast honestly and I
haven't done as many solo episodes um
some of that's been because uh it's been
stress it's been
it just the my stress gets built up and
it's hard for me to
um
breathe yeah I want to be in a calm
enough place when I have these when I do
these so I can try to communicate
earnestly from somewhere in my brain uh
or in my feelings or whatever and it
just
um yeah so I'll just
I just got to breathe
more so hoping have a few a few more
before the end of the year
uh but dude Denmark that's so crazy man
thank you for communicating from Denmark
and good luck with the um disease and
good luck with everything brother we
love you man praise God baby God is
doing work man what else oh somebody got
a tattoo of us right there oh that's
beautiful man be good to yourself says o
it's still bleeding
Jesus
God okay buddy be safe okay be safe oh
this one is cool this one is the little
gang gang guy the little animation guy
that Bartos does and he's a
polishmanicure
and so here we are
just funny taking that first step man um
all right let's hear what we got here
what's going on hey uh SE Von uh this is
Riley and uh what's up
Riley let's hear more baby do it so
recently at my middle school there's
this new kid that's Transit what the
is Middle Middle
School
Middle
School what am I thinking of Middle
School like a what um okay uh yep yep
let's sorry let's hear more
man this new kid that's Transit over the
year since the new
year and all right so he's cool and
stuff all right uh I know this uh might
be offensive I don't know no offense oh
it's fine
but his
uh yeah he's a big black kid
and I I paid him
$3 to know my friend
to like mess with my friend okay so you
paid a brother $3 a mess with your
friend okay we got it I think that's
called what is that
called I don't know let's he
more and guess what he does he slaps him
and he kept on requesting more and more
money and he keeps on trying to get me
to send them more money and I don't
really know what to
do dang homie you that's what see look
man if you start a $3 brother dog you
don't you know what I'm saying you can't
you can't ask for you can't be expecting
$5 Behavior if you you know what I'm
saying you can't even be expecting $10
Behavior at a $3 brother or any $3 hit
man so I think you got to you got to you
got to top him off with the extra that
money I get him another seven and say
hey look this ends here Daddy this
ends here cuz if he slapped him
damn bro you involved in damn crime
brother you in damn crime homie God damn
brother yeah that's look I've been there
you start a couple dollar brother on
some low-key crime and then you can't
stop he want us to you know
because sometime people get motivated a
little bit it doesn't matter what the
Avenue is whether it's uh you know for
the good or the
bad you know in these days crime half of
our government is crime so hell that
dude could be a damn mayor in six months
but God baby yeah seven you I say you
hit him with that seven bucks man
uh let me I might even pay it off for
you man because I don't want you getting
involved in some I don't want you
getting too deep and you still too
young man for that God damn brother oh
yeah I remember I lent a dude $8 some
dude with no
shoes and he bought a bunch of dope and
I had to go down to his family
and their door was inoperable or
something some of the and you had to go
in and out right through their
window by the sink you had to
climb up this plant pot and get in there
I was so scared dude and they were in
there they had a cat that was
dying and they were in there bottle
feeding
it and I was like I do not need my
8 I am getting the out of this
so all right this is a call that came in
hey Theo uh my name is Gabe I'm
from right around the Leon Auburn area
of Maine I know thank you for calling
Gabe I appreciate it up to main yeah i'
been up there and
uh there was a John Travolta
touched where my buddy's daddy said John
Travolta touched his leg once up there
on a ferry said he had beautiful legs
for a 75y old onward main I know you
mentioned before you really like Maine
and I saw you up here in
Portland about a year ago when you came
out with your special
um we just had a uh our first mass
shooting in Maine
and it was actually right down the road
for me at at a bowling alley in a bar
that I I've gone to before and I've gone
to the bowling alley quite a
bit
um I I've always read about this stuff
happening in other places and it just
kind of hits hits at home I mean
literally right down the road
um I know a 14-year-old boy was killed
and it was like a youth night at the
bowling alley
and I think our whole community up here
is really taken back by it and
I I didn't have any family involved I
just knew I knew of a few people who
passed away and obviously it's a small
community and knew who they
were um I just don't I don't think
anyone around here really knows how to
move forward past this I mean with time
I guess but I just
don't I don't know how people do it
being in a in a bigger city and and this
kind of stuff happening all the time me
yeah not
normal it's not
normal yeah it's not normal man I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry that's been
happening in your community
man yeah it happened in
Nashville um every year there's a
there's a place that gets it new val day
H yeah I I don't know what to say you
know and maybe you're not even looking
for me to say
anything maybe just looking for somebody
just to sit here with you for a
minute yeah man I can do that I can just
sit here with you for a
minute if you need to feel something or
whatever yeah I going to sit here with
you and care about you for a minute or
try to you know sometimes when I try to
care about people I
just
I just try to like close my eyes and
just think about how wonderful they are
that's I I think how I do it let me
think how I do
it yeah and I think I just wish I could
do anything to make them feel better you
know
but yeah just know that people are
thinking of you man um you know my
uh when you said it's not normal that's
so
true it's not
normal I don't know you know it's a good
question is it is it it's not normal we
shouldn't do this to each other other
countries don't do this you know I
think every society is really an
experiment you know we've learned a
little bit from previous societies that
stays around but societies get
manipulated and um compromised by
different forces and dark
Forces and then it's an the experiment
changes
um but yeah it' be nice if we could go
back to a time where
we were just more connected to the
nature you
know and when you saw a deer it would
just like it wouldn't run
maybe you know I don't know that could
be delusional too but also back
then a raccoon you might be
looking at a deer and then two raccoons
jump out the tree and you up you
know that's the weird thing it's like is
it normal is soci are we does it nature
always just devolve into something
anarchical I don't
know I don't know but I think
it's it's it's not
comfortable and yeah I'm sorry that that
happened in your community I'm sorry
that every year there's new communities
where it
happens but I sometimes I start to
believe that we're going to get F we're
going to figure this out we're going to
get out of this
we're going to get out of this
pain we're going to climb out you
know the river can see the
moon in the distance of the seventh Moon
the oyster listens to his family like
look dude I gotta get I look I just need
one of these saburns a little you know
hey can you just fade this up a little
the tree learns his ways from the wind
yeah I understand that can you I just I
got to get this um can
you this I gotta get this fade a little
tighter man you
know do not change horses in the middle
of the river yeah I look man I totally
agree I I got four minutes I got to be
up that on ramp so can we I got yeah you
just T tight just decide even it up a
little bit please all right guys uh I
gotta get I gotta go I've been on here
for a long time um
um
but yeah I just got to remember to
breathe
man they they must want us to breathe
God must want us to breathe because he
gave us two places to breathe out
of you
[Music]
know you could do it frontwards
backwards you could do to
um backwards frontwards that's the only
ways you can do it
breathing but uh yeah uh but anyway um
sorry I think my brain's just getting
tired um I want to thank you guys for
your continued support
and what else it's nice man it's a nice
time of year it's a great time of year
to keep our eyes open keep our hearts
open uh do our best back off that wiener
baby and let the Lord touch you that's
what I'm
saying dehand that
wiener and let the Lord touch
you that's what I'm saying baby so I'm
feeling that I'm feeling just feeling
excited about that getting in touch with
uh just better intentions and Spirits
this holiday season
um what else I feel like there's
something I supposed to tell you but I
can't remember what it was um God bless
everybody in Israel and
Palestine uh they got to figure some
Freedom out over there man you know
usually when you hear free a place free
Tibet free Cuba they that there needs to
be some freeing there's you know you
don't otherwise you don't hear it you
know what I'm saying that's you don't
hear the thing you don't hear free um
America you don't hear free Israel you
don't hear free um Russia you don't hear
free
Michigan you don't hear
it so usually it's a good sign that they
got to figure something out
um but I'm praying for my friends in
pain I'm praying for those people in
pain
it is just it's a lot being alive
sometimes is a
lot uh anyway sorry I didn't mean to get
enough sad space there but um we got to
go out and do our best baby and I love
you guys and
um what can we roll out on
um uh this one will get us s uh how
about in enjoy this one right here um
you guys be good to yourselves baby you
deserve
it out in the
cold faithless and dark your stories
Untold come take my hand and walk there
with
me I know a place where we can be
free there is a light
shining for
you guiding your
way helping you through and shadows and
Gloom are all that you
see we
find